I understand that your nice kid grew up
in the suburbs but you have a love of
what you call like extreme culture or
sort of oddball culture or things that
are slightly off the beaten path that
you have an extreme curiosity for I
wouldn't know anything about that where
does that come from and how does that
play out in making your work mainstream
or is there a level you know you'll
always sort of be at a certain level
because the mainstream might react too
personal i don't know i think the
mainstream is welcome more welcoming
these days for stuff that's a little
left of center or offbeat but you know
there's always you know people that push
it and extremes i mean look you can i
mean i used a sideshow was always been
interested in circus sideshows and i got
to do a documentary for the travel
channel in 2003 and that was like a
dream job because i love that subject
but you used to have to go to the circus
to see a heavily tattooed person now you
just have to go to you know Venice Beach
or anywhere in the country I mean it's
not to the mainstream has embraced a lot
of more extreme more extremes in popular
culture and I think I I'm still
interested myself and and offbeat
material off beats butts but it has to
strike me I mean if I'm going to do a
project I just something has to click
and resonate with me to want to do
something if its ambitious sometimes
it's more whimsical and I can just do
something a short video and it won't be
as involved or laborious is a
feature-length project but no I always
have just I've never really
psychoanalyzed it I just think that it's
something that I know that I just always
been curious and I've always been
interested in like you know the back
pages of magazines I go to the back
first you know into the classified ads
or just the more you know just a little
like what's going on underneath the
surface I'm sure there's a good
therapist bill in there somewhere trying
to get to the bottom of it but it's
always been ever since I was a kid
something that I have always I'm a
collector I collect things comic books
records books which is a problem because
I don't know what to do with it all but
I have always just been interested in
stuff and I've been interested in oral
history and I've been interested in an
unusual history and and and I think also
I then if you then find people you have
find kindred spirits that are interested
in the same things and you then kind of
build up a network of friends and
associates and people speak the same
language and but I've also even I I like
mainstream culture too I mean I'm very
interested in just everything that's
that's going on and kind of how it all
just you know you know as part of this
big landscape that we live in culturally
and you know but things that just you
know the stuff that I'm reading about
you know I mean I'll still I'll still
will go to the back pages of magazines
you